>> Good question, David. Novelty had use with newness,
the unexpectedness had use with something non-obvious or surprising.
Perhaps this will become clearer if I take an example. So in my deal, we
decide to entertain a group of 20 friends. We already know how to make soufflés
according to a particular recipe. We'll make soufflé for 20 friends this time.
We have never made soufflé for 20 people, so something is novel, something new,
something we haven't done earlier. On the other hand, we have known this recipe
for ages. Something unexpected would be if we come up with a new recipe for
this soufflé which taste dramatically different, surprisingly different.
Not just something new, but something unexpected. So far we have been talking
about the product of creativity, the result of creativity, the outcome of
creativity. What about the process of creativity? You use it on here some and
other, both of these terms are important. Let's first look at the term other.
In this course we've only talked about several processes of creativity.
An analogical reasoning is a fundamental process of creativity. You already
explored an analogical reasoning in the context of designing. We just did
that when were talking about design thinking. One might be able to design a new
kind of water pump, but composing several water pumps in series if one can
analogically transfer a design factor from the domain of electrical circuits.
Was a very good example. Similarly under analogical reasoning,
we were talking about the processes that might be used to come up with a model
the atomic structure the analogy to the model the solar system, which clearly is
a creative process that cuts across large number dimensions of space and
time. Another place where we talked about creative processes was when we were
talking about explanation based learning. It seems creative, if the robot can go
to the kitchen, and use the flower pot as a cup to bring you coffee.
Here are three other processes of creativity. Emergence, re-representation, and
serendipity. A simple example of emergences. If I draw three lines. One, two,
three. Then a triangle emerges out of it. The triangleness doesn't belong to any
single line. I was not even trying to draw a triangle. I just drew three lines,
and a triangle emerged out of it. Emergence of the triangle to the drawing
the three lines is a kind of creativity. Re-representation occurs when
the original representation of the problem is not conducive to problem solving.
So we re-represent the problem and then commence problem solving.
To see an example of this. Let's go back to atomic structure and
solve this problem. Suppose that we have a model sort of system which uses
the word the planets revolve around the sun. You also have a model of the atom,
and this uses the term the electron rotates around the nucleus.
The model of the sun had the word revolve. The model of the atom has
the word rotates. The two vocabularies are different. If you were to stay with,
with this couple of sort of presentations mapping between rotate and reward
would be very hard. On the hand, suppose we were to re-represent this problem.
Re-represent the atomic structure by growing the nucleus in the middle and
the electron around it. We represent the solar system by drawing the sun in
the middle and the earth around it. Then in this new representation,
we can see the similarity, we can do the mock-up.
This re-representation is another fundamental process of creativity.
Serendipity can be of many types and can occur in many different situations.
One kind of serendipity occurs when I'm trying to address a problem but
I'm unable to address it. So I suspend the goal and I start doing
something different. Later, at some other time, I come across a solution, and
I connect it with the previous, suspended goal. The story has it that in 1941 in
France, Josh Mistral's wife asked him to help her open a dress
by pulling on a zipper because it was stuck. Mistral struggled with the zipper,
but couldn't pull it down. Later on one day, Mistral was walking his dog,
when he found that some birds were stuck to the dog's legs. Curious about this,
Mistral looked at the bird closely under the microscope,
he then connected the solution, the bird solution to the opening of
the zipper problem and out of that was born the notion of Velcro which you and
I now use on a common basis. But just like the word other was important here,
these are three processes in addition to the process we already discussed in
this class. The word some is also important here.
This is not an exhaustive list. There are in fact additional things we can add.
For example, another potential process here is called conceptual combination.